I'm petrified of you host of attainment
and today I want to talk to you about
one of the books I wrote I brought a
book a few years ago called 25 loss for
doing the impossible and when I wrote
this book I mean it sold 150,000 copies
right now it's in five different
languages Polish Russian Chinese English
and I'm missing one Romanian
that's right Romanian right and it did
very well we were not expecting for it
to do this well it did very well you
know most readers are from the States
then it's Russia then it's Australia
just started grown and grown and grown
but I was having a conversation just the
other day and somebody was asking me Pat
if everybody keeps saying when you were
in high school you grew up a regular kid
from broken up family 1.8 GPA and you
don't have any money in your family and
your father was this and your mother was
here and how did you become and how did
you change yourself right so when I
wrote this book 25 volts for doing the
impossible it's broken down into three
different steps right first step is how
to recreate yourself how to identify
your cause then go make history so I
want to focus and emphasize today mainly
on the first step which is how to
recreate yourself because everybody who
all of a sudden goes from having a a
pass that no one thought that person was
going to be who they were going to be
there's a point there's an epiphany
moment where they change and there's a
very consistent formula on how to do
that I want to share ten of the laws on
this video with you and then from there
if you want to read the rest I'll send
you where you can go get the book and
read it for yourself okay
so how do you recreate yourself how does
one completely change their identity how
does one go from being recognized as
having this kind of a reputation to
completely change in a reputation first
steps first very simple this the first
thing you got to do first thing you got
to do is you got a set of goal that
seems very difficult to you it seems
impossible to you it seems something
that everybody was there's no way in the
world you could do this and you gotta go
hit this goal okay you got to go do this
thing
seems extremely impossible you gotta go
actually make that thing become a
reality it could be very small little
things initially it could be I want to
go out there make $50,000 in a year I
want to make $100,000 in a year I want
to make $50,000 in a month they could be
I want to go out there and you know
become number one in the company I want
to go out there and become a vice
president with a company marketing
director the goal has to be a difficult
governor almost 30 pounds in the next 30
days I want to go out there and do it's
got to be extremely difficult every time
you go out there and do something that
seems difficult to you what it's not
what ends up happening is your mind and
your heart start believing in the words
that's coming out of your mouth when
your mind and your heart believes in the
words that's coming out of your mouth
and you continuously then set another
goal that you do that seems impossible
then eventually whatever comes out of
here these two trusts because it's going
to become a reality so your credibility
on what comes out of here is very high
here but you got to start it first and
that's when you start seeing yourself
you don't recognize you anymore don't
you don't recognize it anymore because
you're changing you so the ten laws of a
first side of recreating yourself number
one invest into your identity I've been
told so many times I've sold stocks I've
sold mutual funds I sell insurance we do
very well business-wise but I've been
told to by so many different things
invest into real estate investment to
this and nothing in the world has given
me better returns than me investing into
one thing and that's been of my identity
nothing nothing ever has all these books
that are here all the books on my house
all the seminars I've been to all the
places I've traveled to all the places I
want to just meet one person to have a
one-hour meeting or have breakfast with
this person to learn one thing about him
investing in my identity is by far the
most important law you got to keep in
mind so law number one is invest into
your identity number two let the right
ones in it's very important to DES let
the right ones in what do I mean by that
Association you gotta let people and
some people don't let anybody and if you
don't let anybody and nobody can direct
you because nobody really knows where
you're at with your life you have to
have a handful of people that you'll let
n who can give you feedback but you've
got to let the right mentors the right
influence get in to have influence
over you number three protect your
credibility score let me explain to what
that means your credibility score you
know we all when you're buying a house
or you're buying a car whatever you're
doing they're going to check your FICO
score to see how good it is then they
give you a loan here's $50,000 $100,000
$1,000,000 on your your credibility
score is just as important if not more
important than anything else here's why
if you say what you're going to do and
you actually do what you say you're
going to do your credibility score goes
higher who does that improve and who
does that help one it helps you because
you trust you when you say going to do
something you actually do it second who
does it help your friends your family
they like you three who does it help the
people that do business with you when
your credibility score goes up because
what you say is what you do more people
want to be in business with you because
it's very important for in business
force business partner for somebody you
doing business with to keep their word
if you keep saying what you're going to
do and you don't do it your credibility
score is low not only do you not like
yourself not only does your friends and
family not trust you nobody wants to do
business with you you got to increase
your credibility score in order to get
the right help or unusual for strengthen
your greatest weapon the mind is the
greatest weapon you got to you got to
feed this thing regularly so often I
meet people spoke to one of the guys I
think it's one the most talented guys
I've met in my life I said what a waste
of a mind it is you've been given then
your mind is that smart but you refuse
to read books what a waste can you
imagine that brain that computers like
having the most incredible computer that
you never ever use or do anything with
the software that's in this computer
what are ways to have such a platform to
not do anything with that's your mind
you got to strengthen your greatest
weapon which is this law number five
challenge your way of thinking you got a
constant challenge your way of thinking
here's the question I always ask myself
and I ask other people as well if your
way of thinking worked would you be in
the position you're in today so if your
way of thinking doesn't work you need to
find a new way of thinking to get the
results that you want because there is a
problem with your way of thinking in any
specific area of your life
if your way of thinking doesn't work
you've got to challenge your way of
thinking most of us have a challenge
with that because we don't like to be
wrong we don't like to say it's our
fault we don't like to say we're
mediocre or not there yet or average but
you've got a challenge your way of
thinking if you're willing to challenge
your way of thinking you're putting
yourself in a position to get into new
heights next law number six no your why
your why is very simple but the why
generally a lot of people say things
like oh I want to be financially free I
want to have a big house I want have a
nice car I want to do believe it or not
that's all a byproduct yes I have nice
cars I have live in a nice home I black
cards and all this stuff and I travel
like all over the world I'm in Dubai I'm
in Paris last couple weeks and I go to
New Orleans and we're all we're this way
yes all that stuff is great
but that's purely a byproduct of the
real why of my life which was many years
ago when I remember seeing my father who
had a heart attack and he went to the
hospital UCLA Medical Center and I saw
this man lose 40 pounds within a week
and I'm sitting there at the hospital
fighting every single nurse I go
downstairs
I'm in my fourth focus I've lost
everything I have and I sit and I say
this is it for me I'm making a decision
tonight I am making a decision tonight
I'm crying for 30 minutes this is never
my dad's not gonna die from stress
caused by financial issues if my dad's
gonna pass away it's going to be because
a natural cause came back made a list of
what I wanted to do boom went the rest
was history but it wasn't I want to have
nice cars the cars the money the
financial freedom came up a byproduct of
real strong why's that are in here the
person that doesn't believe you could do
it for you to look at that person in the
eye and say why you really did it for
your family your mom and dad to tell
your product they're proud of you for
you to do something that no one thought
was ever possible it's got to be the
real deep wider you write down next work
like it's 1880 quite frankly that's a
very controversial message today because
you know you got books like 4-hour
workweek by Tim Ferriss who became a
multi-millionaire by writing a book
called 4-hour workweek because great
it's like these commercials late at
night is very smart by the way to write
a book like that because everybody wants
to work less so it's like saying how to
lose 50 pounds in two weeks everyone
would read the book oh this is so great
and there is no such thing as how to
lose 50 pounds those drinks you drink
this drink you lose 15 pounds in one
night but it's not good for you the
4-hour workweek is a myth it doesn't
exist it doesn't happen for those that
want to play in the big leagues I don't
know anybody that has a 4-hour workweek
that's the top achiever I don't know any
single person in Hollywood in business I
don't know who compete at a very high
level 4-hour workweek is for somebody
who wants to be on a low radar nobody
paying attention to you you're just
getting by making enough money to pay
your bills and you travel and that's
what the book is about okay if you read
it I'm talking about working the way we
worked in 1880 the average American
today works on a late 30 hours a week 35
36 - high 36 37 hours a week back in
1880s we used to work 69 hours a week
50-69 67 hours a week this is according
to the Department of Labor it's going
back to real work ethic it's really
working people are frightened of working
I love what Gary Vaynerchuk says when
he's hustling guy he talks about
hustling waking up early in the morning
going this going that you see video like
Grant Cardone who is obsessed with
working you see Jordans work at the
Kobe's work ethic you know these guys
that wake up in the morning and go at
night dark dark not up you know Sun Sun
let me come home no so if you want to do
the impossible then you want to recreate
yourself and you want to work 9:00 to
5:00 I had a friend that said yeah I
made a planet by 30 years old I want her
to take Friday's off and Saturday's off
and Sundays off that's not my goal I
don't have a desire to do that why do I
want to take Friday Saturdays and
Sundays off and only work four days a
week I don't want to do that I have no
desire to do that and those who do the
impossible typically work Edison was
known with his wife it's a very
interesting story when you talk about
Edison Edison's wife would say he would
come to the house I would make him some
food he would go back to work would come
back take 20-minute naps go back to it
would come back 20 minute and I was 15
minute nap 20 minute he's just constant
working well let's see what Edison did
we have a light we have all the TIC
Edison out what if you only work 15
hours a week what if you only work 30
hours a week I'm sitting with a candle
right now if you only work 15 hours a
week
this dude works 70 80 hours a week thank
God he had strong work ethic and he
wasn't living in an economic time like
this
where to pull it you know the PC police
is going around saying that's not
politically correct you can't listen to
any of the media that tells you about
work and Huffington Post article it's
not healthy to work more than 40 hours a
week written because viewers are going
to read that article it's a bunch of
nonsense you go get advice from
performers who are playing in that game
not the other guys I want to make sure
you read a 4-hour work week book and all
this other crap anyways I get upset when
I read that stuff cause it's a bunch of
gibberish that fools people and then
they wonder how come they don't get the
results law number eight is elevate your
imagination to a whole new level I'm
explain to what I mean by elevate your
imagination to a whole new level
it's a weapon that's been given to
everybody everybody when you go to sleep
how do you go in to say how to go to
sleep think about it we all have a story
right how you go to sleep who creates
that story you do it's your imagination
you're in charge of your imagination
just just so you know that so if I'm
going to sleep at night with the thought
of oh my god my bills promotion that guy
fear fear fear fear fear fear fear I
wake up with fear but what if you go to
imaginations asleep like this and what
if that one day I'm giving a talk in
front of 50,000 people and there's an
audience there my wives and kids are
cinema my mom's buy don't you know I'm
giving this talk and it's on the time
magazine covering what if there's
something what if what if this one thing
oh this is so great what that's the
stuff that you gotta take control of
your imagination if you let it loose
it'll really mess with you that's law
number eight elevate your imagination to
all them when you read the book all
these things are obviously more specific
law number nine is to be curious as
callous curious as Alice Alice was
curious obviously Alice in Wonderland
right you gotta be curious you've got to
be curious to read books you got to be
curious to watch your videos I was
speaking to somebody named Bobby the
other day says my Saturday mornings and
early in the morning when I wake up I
watch four hours of YouTube and audio is
what I do on Sundays i watch this many
hours of YouTube videos on how to do
this and I listen to audio every week I
finished three audio tapes every single
week you know my English isn't that good
but I like listening to audios because I
understand when I listen to audio so it
doesn't matter it's curious for
information because it's out there
accessible to everybody especially today
more than ever before
no one could say I don't know how this
thing works it's a lame excuse all our
staff that I have here working with us
right we had a guy that came and started
working with us he's never had any
experience more you how much experience
have you had in the past with social
media when you got started with us how
much Twitter experience did you have
really how many followers zero followers
social media nothing
Mario is curious he would sit here
listen and watch things on how would
working go research and now Mario's one
of the best you should follow Mario
what's your tag on our social angular
social on twitter aguilar social and go
befriend him on facebook and your
Instagram is what what's your Instagram
Aguilar social really interesting he's
learned on social media right he's now
learned how social media works but he
was curious to learn you got to tap into
that curious side of you number 10 is
break away from the old you it goes back
to the first thing I said when I opened
up the video which is write down
something you want to do that seems
impossible and go hit it and break away
from the old you just because your
friends family or your cousins have
created a reputation about you that all
your friends say that doesn't mean
that's true just because in high school
you were a knucklehead kid or you hung
around with people's everybody called
you the chump or the loser or the smarty
this guy didn't get good grades or
whatever that's their identity they're
creating for you you don't need to buy
that identity that make sense you choose
the identity that's going to be with you
for you you are determining that it's
not on anybody else
most people allow other people to create
their identity you got to take
responsibility of it and let the right
ones in who can elevate and challenge
you and push you and say you're too
cocky too arrogant it's all about you
change yourself people don't want to
work with you you got to get better you
got to read this book finish that book
why don't you reading that book did you
get to that why do you tell me you want
a winner you still don't go out then
drink then don't tell me you you need
people like that in your life and the
next thing you know saying this person
believes in me did new identity once you
have the new identity then you got to go
identify your cause and you got to go
make history so I'm gonna do this for
you real quick I've never done this I
produce how many videos have we done
three four hundred videos hundreds of
videos I've never talked to my my book
Mario said Pat why don't you do a book
on doing the impossible that's what
we're doing today so here's what I want
you to go and ask
to do a couple things for me one I want
you to go on Amazon can we put the link
Paul let's put the link up it'll be on
the bottom as well you can probably put
the link they can click right there go
to Amazon I want you to buy this book 25
watts for doing impossible it's a very
simple book to read and here's what I'm
going to do for you
this is what we'll do today anybody who
buys the book reads the book and post a
review on Amazon you can tweet aguilar
social that you read the book and you
posted a review on Amazon and what we'll
do is we will simply send you five doing
the impossible wristbands to you so one
you get to wear it mari wears it all the
time until you came give it away to
people around you to be challenging
themselves to do the impossible but it
will only be given for the first ten
people that buy the book and post the
review on on Amazon I think you know
when you think about books there's not a
lot of money in selling books but there
is money in building a business and
changing your identity this is valuable
information in this book that's helped
me get to where I'm at today and I think
it can help you do the same as well so
go to Amazon the link is right there by
the book finish the book poster review
tweet aguilar social and we will send
you five response of doing the
impossible but ultimately make a
decision to recreate yourself and get
after your dreams and leave a legacy for
the people that love you and for the
people that matter the most to you
that's my message of the week and be
sure to subscribe to this channel as
well take care
you